(drum music)
- We want to have a
conversation here today.
We want to talk about substantive issues.
I think it's really important
to hear both sides of issues
because it often makes you
reexamine your own positions
and get deeper insights
into your own positions.
We'll try to focus on the
facts as much as possible.
And everyone gets extra
points for citing true facts
and not false facts, no
trivia, no personalities,
just hard hitting issue analysis.
With that, let me start
with the first question,
which is a yes/no
question, president Trump,
who just appointed Larry Kudlow as his new
economic advisor--
- No.
(audience laughs)
- In seeing, no, no, no,
that's not the question.
In seeing Larry Kudlow on TV, he said,
you're looking handsome, Larry.
Is Larry Kudlow handsome?
(audience laughs)
- Well, he used to do
Cadillac commercials,
so yeah, the guy is handsome.
- So he's handsome, Bob?
- No.
(audience laughs)
Okay.
Well, I think we've run
that one to the ground.
That was a good debate.
- Yes, thank you, thank you for that.
- Good opinion.
- Can I just add a word of...
Of welcome to Stephen Moore
because for the last 15 years.
- More than that.
- Maybe 20 years, 30, 40?
Stephen and I have debated on television
with Larry Kudlow very
often and I have enjoyed
debating you, Steve, I think
you're wrong most of the time,
but no seriously, I've
enjoyed debating Steve
and I consider you a real friend.
When you are debating on
television, one thing that you,
you don't have a chance to see
the person you're debating,
so it's a kind of surreal
experience, Steve,
to have you, a hologram of
you sitting right next to me.
- Yeah, I used to say,
with, because we did this
almost 20 years on CNN
every week, they called us
the dynamic duo, and
every once in a while,
like, every once in a blue
moon, Bob Reich got it right,
you know, and so I used to say, you know,
even a blind squirrel finds
an acorn every once in a while
and that's true.
- Thank you for that.
- Okay, gentlemen.
(men laugh)
So now that we've settled that
and the Larry Kudlow issue
to some extent, knowing there's two sides
to that one as well, I want to talk about
the following topics in order.
I'm gonna start with money in politics.
I want to go to crony capitalism.
I want to talk about
free trade and tarries,
the 2017 tax bill and income inequality,
so we're gonna discuss those issues.
We'll be here three or four hours,
but let's see if we can get
through this fairly quickly.
So let's start with money in politics,
is money in politics a
problem in America, Bob?
- Yes.
- Steve?
- Yeah, because our government
is way, way, way too big.
- Well, let me elaborate.
(audience laughs)
What we have here is, the
term crony capitalism, Steve,
is one that I keep on hearing,
many people call themselves
conservative Republicans use, and I agree.
I have seen really over the last 50 years,
my first job was in Robert
F. Kennedy's Senate office.
I was an intern in 1967.
And I've seen just this
tide of money coming into
Washington, now the interesting
question and I think here
is where we may disagree
is cause and effect.
And I have seen the
tide of money coming in
mostly from big corporations
and from Wall Street
and from wealthy individuals
in order to influence
government, and Steve, I
don't know whether you see it
that way, or whether you
see government being large
and as it gets large,
there's more money coming in
to influence it, but there's
no question that money
has taken over much of our policy making
and I hope you agree with me
and that's a real problem.
- So look, I mean, by
the way, let me just say,
right from the start that
I want to thank my friends
at Young America's
Foundation for sponsoring me
to come here, so thank you, yeah for that.
I think the causality
goes both directions.
I mean, I think there's a
lot of naivete on the left.
People say, oh my God, there's
so much money in politics,
they're spending so
much money on lobbying,
much money on campaigns,
but folks, we have a four
trillion dollar budget.
Four trillion dollars.
Is it a surprise that
companies and special interests
and whether it's the gun lobby
or this lobby or that lobby
is going to spend a lot of money, in fact,
I'm surprised that the
lobbyists aren't spending
even more money trying to elect candidates
and trying to influence
Congress because when I first
came to Washington, you
mentioned that you worked for
Robert F Kennedy, when
I came to Washington,
I'm a little younger than you are in 1983,
the federal budget was
at that time, I'll never forget
this 'cause I was working
in the Reagan administration at that time
and I was working for Jim Miller, who was
the budget director, '84, '85
and we introduced the first
one trillion dollar budget
in American history, we
were very proud of that
as Reaganites and I'll just
tell you one really interesting
quick story about that.
So Jim Miller was supposed
to go on the Today Show
which was the show with Katie
Couric and he couldn't do it
that morning because he
got sick and he called me
and he said, Steve, can you
go on Katie Couric's show
and defend the president's budget?
And I spent literally the next two nights
just completely cramming
every statistic I knew
in the budget, I knew what the budget was
for the army, you know, the
Department of Agriculture,
World Series, whatever
it was, so I was ready
for any question Katie
Couric might ask me.
And Katie, the lights
come on, cameras rolling,
Katie Couric kind of
growls at me, she says,
Mr. Moore, I see that
Ronald Reagan is introducing
the first one trillion dollar
budget in American history.
Says, my first question
for you this morning is
how many zeroes are there in a trillion?
(men laugh)
You know, I just melted down.
It was the worst interview of my life,
but my point is, it was a
trillion dollar budget back then.
By the way, there are
12 zeroes in a trillion,
I know that now by heart.
But now we're at four
trillion and even adjusting
for inflation, we've doubled it.
We're spending way too much money.
We have so much crap in the tax code.
One of the things we tried
to do in this tax bill.
We didn't, we succeeded a
little bit but not much,
is get rid of all the
junk in the tax system.
One of the things that I
think Bob and I might agree on
is the idea of let's get rid
of all the special interest
loopholes in the tax system
for all of the special lobbies
and get the rates down and that would be
an efficient tax system, so less spending
and a simpler tax system
I think would reduce
the influence of the lobbyists.
Now why would you be against that?
- I'm not, I'm not, again,
it's cause and effect.
What I've witnessed, and
this is certainly the case
at least since the mid '80s,
is that the lobbyists come in
and they want exemptions,
they want loopholes,
they want everything
because they want to justify
to their industry and to
their trade association
and to others that they've,
basically they're worth
all of the money that they're charging
and that set of loopholes
and that set of exemptions
makes everything more complicated.
It makes the tax code more complicated,
it makes the enforcement more complicated
and also it results in less
revenue for the government
so it drives up deficits.
There is almost no way to
stop all of this, short of--
- A flat tax, oh, sorry. (laughs)
- No.
(audience laughs)
Short of major campaign finance reform
and full disclosure of who's
actually contributing what
to every campaign or
against every campaign.
And public financing and a
lot of things that can be done
even with Citizens United
and Steve, I think you and I
would agree on much of that.
- So let me just give one
example of something I worked
this past, you know, six
to nine months trying
to get rid of, a special interest
provision in the tax code,
something probably a
lot of you in this room,
I'm just guessing probably
favor, which is, you know,
we have these massive
giveaways in the tax code.
To the wind and solar industry.
We pay them money to
produce energy because
they're so inefficient relative
to coal and natural gas
and the industry even admitted,
the wind industry said
there would be no wind
industry in America today
were it not for these tax
subsidies and guess what,
we couldn't get rid of
'em because a lot of your
Democratic friends, you know,
said they couldn't possibly
support that and some Republicans as well.
My point is, too oftentimes
liberals say, well,
we're against the special interests,
we're against this or that,
but when it's their special
interest, they're in favor of it.
- Well what about, but oil
and gas, Steve, get so much
subsidies.
- Get rid of those
subsidies too.
- Let's get rid of
all of those subsidies,
but I don't understand
how the carried interest
subsidy interest loophole.
- I wanted to get rid of that too.
- Well, wait a minute, how did
it survive, because everybody
- Because there were a lot--
- Everybody, including the President--
- There were about eight
private equity billionaires,
I mean, it sort of makes your point.
Who give a lot of money
to the Republican party
who said we can't support this
bill if you get rid of it.
I fought it, you know,
and in the end of the day,
that private interest loophole
is still in the tax system.
I'm embarrassed by that, but
I'm gonna make a second run
at that, I promise you guys.
- I'm embarrassed by it too
and I'm embarrassed by a lot of things,
but we can't get rid of it
and all of these loopholes
and all of this corporate
welfare until we get some control
on campaign finance and
you would, it sounds like
you're agreeing with me on this.
- You know, I...
What I'm for is people
disclosing what they're giving.
I think we should have open,
if you're gonna give money
it should all be disclosed
and let people out there see.
- Full disclosure.
(men laugh)
- By the way, I just
have to make this point,
that you were saying that
Robert Reich won this
very prestigious Time
magazine award for being
one of the 10 most successful
cabinet secretaries.
Aren't there only 12?
(men laugh)
- [Robert] No, there are eight, actually.
- Just teasing, couldn't resist.
- But, look, I think quite
seriously, this is something
that we have a lot of agreement
on, and I've talked to
some extremely conservative
members of Congress
who agree on this too,
it's very difficult to do
and the only way we're
gonna do it is if we get
big corporations and
the left and the right,
Democrats and Republicans
to form a coalition
and force full disclosure--
- I am for it, I am for it.
- Stop the revolving door, at
least slow the revolving door.
- I'm for that.
- Do all of these things.
- But you know what, I
mean, look, I worked on
the campaign, I was a
senior economic advisor
for Donald Trump, what, you know what,
and I went with him to all
these areas of the country.
I mean, I heard his speeches
over and over again.
His most powerful applause
line other than build the wall
was drain the swamp and Americans, look,
Americans are much more even
upset about this than you are,
Bob, I mean, I'll give you
a statistic that I think
summarizes everything that's
wrong with our government today
in Washington, I live in
the belly of the beast.
I live in the swamp.
Three of the five wealthiest
counties in America
are in and around Washington DC.
Now how did that happen?
Because you know what folks?
We don't produce anything.
All we produce is lawyers,
lobbyists, special interests,
politicians, rules and
regulations, and we're getting rich
off it, and you know
what, the American people
are getting pretty upset about it, so.
- Well, let me just, I
don't want to go too long
on this, because we have agreement here.
In 1976, 3% of retiring
members of Congress
became lobbyists, 3%.
Today, 49%.
- Pathetic.
- Of retiring members of
Congress, from both parties,
become lobbyists, and I think that's--
- I'm surprised it's that low.
- And I think it's a testament
to the amount of money
that is circulating in Washington
and that's got to stop, so
we have an agreement, good.
- Let's move on to tariffs,
so Bob, you were an early
opponent of the Transpacific Partnership,
and I think Steve has
got some criticisms of it
but was basically a
proponent of free trade
and of the Transpacific
Partnership, although
you can speak for
yourself, but tell me why
you were opposed to the
Transpacific Partnership
and does that mean you're
in league with Donald Trump?
(audience laughs)
- Well, last question
first, no, but I didn't like
the dispute mechanisms, in
fact, there was a similar
dispute mechanism in a
much smaller form in NAFTA,
the North American Free
Trade Act, but actually
under TPP, you have a much larger version
and that dispute mechanism
is between any corporation,
for example, that feels
that for some reason
a member state, a member
country, to the TPP
has discriminated against
them or there's a non tariff
barrier, health, safety,
environmental regulation,
labor regulation, whatever,
and that dispute can be
under the TPP, could be
dealt with by arbitrators and
the arbitrators are not
necessarily selected
by any member country but
the net result is that
anybody who has a grievance
and could be rewarded damages
from those health, safety or
environmental regulations.
If you follow my argument,
that means that the TPP
could discourage any member
country from generating
any protections for the
health, safety or environment
or labor and that to
me is not only an issue
of sovereignty but it also
is an issue of just politics.
It means it would be harder,
that much harder actually
to protect members of that society.
- In general, though,
are you for free trade?
Do you think that's a good idea?
As a principle?
- In general, I,
in general as a principle,
of course, I think free trade
is a good idea, but see, this
is the interesting issue,
Henry, we have debated free
trade for years and I've been
on the side of well, stronger
environmental and labor
protections, Steve, you've
been on the side of free trade.
We've debated deficits,
I've been on the side of
well, deficits may not
always be a problem.
You and other conservatives
have been on the side of
we really do need to control deficits.
We've debated states' rights
and I've been on the side of
federal government does
really need to preempt states
and you and other conservatives
have been on the side
of states' rights, we debated Russia
and I've been saying, you
know, we really shouldn't be
so hard on Russia, and you
have been on the side of
we have to be more aggressive on Russia.
Every one of these issues, we
have completely flipped around
under Donald Trump, every one
of them is now the opposite.
- So I mean, look.
I always say about Donald
Trump, you know, 'cause I've
gotten to know him very
well and I admire a lot
about Donald Trump, but look,
there is a good and a bad
and an ugly, when it comes to Donald Trump
and every morning...
- [Robert] Do you want
to assign percentages
to each of those?
(audience laughs)
- Every morning, this is
not being taped, right?
But no, every morning
when I say my prayers,
I say please God, let the
angel on his shoulder,
not the devil on his
other shoulder, prevail.
So when it comes to issues
like Russia, you know,
I don't understand this
dalliance with even what he said
today, congratulating
Putin on the election.
Why would you congratulate
a guy who rakes elections
on winning an election?
So you're right about
that, now on this issue.
- I do have a theory to explain that.
(audience laughs)
- I'm not so sure I want to hear it.
On this trade thing, I
mean, this is getting to be
a very complicated issue,
we're gonna see in the next
week or so a major call for
a major tariff against China.
I have to confess, I'm
not an expert on the TPP
so I'm not gonna really get into that.
I will say this, that
I learned my economics
from Milt and Friedman,
who I think are two
great economists, and
they always talk about
the four pillars of
prosperity, and those pillars,
and I think they're just
important to write down.
Sound money, I think we all agree on that,
a sound currency that retains its value.
Second of all you need free trade.
Third of all, you need a
light hand of regulation
and fourth a good tax
system, and I still believe
that to this day, that if you
get those four things right,
you're gonna have a prosperous economy.
Trump challenges the conventional
wisdom of conservatives
on a lot of these things,
there's no question about it.
On trade, we can get into
this into a bigger way.
I think trade, I mean, I think Trump,
there's new, what I call
a Trump trade doctrine
and what that doctrine is...
Using, look, the United States is the hub
of the global economy, right,
and every other country
is a spoke and what
Trump is basically saying
and I've talked to him about this is
whether it's China, whether it's Japan
or whether it's Korea
or whether it's Mexico,
they need us more than we need them
so let's say we had, God
forbid, a trade war with China.
What would it mean for the United States?
Well, it'd mean when you go
to Wal-mart, you might have
to pay 10 cents more for
toothpaste or you might have
to pay $29 more for a
cellphone 'cause a lot of these
phones are made in China,
if China can't sell to us
they go into a recession,
right, and I think
what Trump is basically
trying to do here is
use that leverage and that's
why, remember the other day
when he said, we can win a trade
war or something like that,
I mean, with Trump you have
to kind of read through
what he's saying, what he meant to say is,
we have a strategic advantage
over them because if it gets
to that point, they have
more to lose than we do
and they're gonna blink
first, I think that's what,
and by the way, you
can disagree with Trump
on the policy, right, I mean,
you can say this is stupid,
like, I thought the steel
tariffs were stupid.
- The steel?
- The steel tariffs I
thought were a bad idea
because all you're doing is
raising the price of steel.
I told the president,
I said, you're not even
gonna create factory jobs
here because for every one
steel worker, we have 50
workers in manufacturing
that use steel, now our steel's
gonna be 20% more expensive
than the steel, so it doesn't
even work in that respect,
but I will say this, you
know, and you know this
because you've done
this too, I mean, I went
with Donald Trump to
Pennsylvania, Ohio, Michigan,
West Virginia, Iowa, those
blue states that went red
and I would say that if Trump
had taken a conventional
Republican position on trade,
Hillary Clinton would be
president today, so this is
a challenge for those of us
who believe in free trade, right?
We haven't convinced the
American people that free trade
is good.
- But don't you think
a lot of that has to do
with the failure of both
parties to deal with
the consequences of technology?
- That's true too.
- Which is actually having
a much bigger effect.
- I totally agree with you.
- On jobs.
- By the way, let me just, on steel,
the reason we're losing steel jobs is not
because of trade, it's
because if you go, when I was
12 years old, I grew up in
Chicago, my parents took me
to a steel mill in Michigan,
I mean, that was like
a 19th century sweatshop
with thousands of workers
carrying around heavy
beams, I mean, truly,
drudgery work, you go into--
- And a lot of injuries.
A lot of injuries.
- Yeah, today steel mills
are people walking around,
it's all being done robotics,
Trump is wrong on this.
We're not losing steel
jobs because of trade.
It's because of, and by the
way, that's gonna continue.
10 years from now there
won't be any steel jobs,
probably, right, because of technology.
- Right, but back, if it's
true that both parties
have failed to deal with
the quote unquote losers,
the people who are losing
their, what had been
middle class jobs because
of first technology,
secondly globalization, then
isn't the debate over tariffs
sort of beside the point,
I mean, shouldn't we say,
let's not, let's not try to
protect industries with tariffs.
Let's try to make it easier
for people to move from
job to job and get better
and better and better jobs
with better education,
better job training,
more of a re-employment assistance?
- Yeah, yes.
- Put that down, that's another issue.
- (laughs) No, I mean,
you're absolutely right.
I mean, now look, the problem
is, like Hillary would go
to these towns in West
Virginia, we went to these
coal towns, and you know,
these places have been just
decimated, in no small
part, in my opinion,
because of Obama
regulations that just killed
the coal industry, now,
there's an example though, Bob,
where Trump has gotten rid of
a lot of those regulations,
and guess what, the coal industry is back.
We're, and my point is,
though, Hillary went and said
exactly what you said, oh,
you can do something else.
We'll retrain you for this or that.
- No, no, politically, that's--
- It's her thing to
tell a guy who's worked
in a coal mine for 25 years, oh, you know,
you're not gonna be
able to do that anymore.
You're gonna do something else,
but I'll give you another statistic.
One out of 11 males in
America today is hired,
what they do for a living
is drive a vehicle.
Now how many of those jobs
do you think will still exist
12 years from now?
- Four and a half million
are gonna be eliminated.
- Yeah, exactly, so this
adjustment is happening,
it's the issue of our time,
frankly, I mean, folks,
this technological boom that's coming,
whether it's artificial intelligence,
whether it's robotics, whether
it's the driverless cars,
they are gonna change life in
this country and on the planet
in ways that nobody is looking
at and make these other
issues small.
- But so what does government
do in these situations?
You want the government
smaller, but it seems to me
that if we're going to help
people who lose their jobs
in these instances and
there are no other jobs,
what do we say to these people?
- Don't we have to have
stronger safety nets?
Don't we have to have a
universal basic income?
Don't we have to have a larger
earned income tax credit?
Don't we have to have
a re-employment system
that provides education and job retraining
that is really useful to these people?
In other words, politically,
both of us agree
it's not possible to say to these people,
we're gonna get you another job
or you're going to get another job,
but don't we have to be serious
about making it possible
for these people?
- Well, look, I'm not one who believes
that this is the end of
work and end of jobs.
I mean, there will be jobs
in the year 2025 and 2030
and 2035, there'll probably be more jobs
than there are today, but
they'll be different kinds
of jobs, and we're not, I
mean, my point is, look,
the kinds of things you're
talking about small potatoes
in the grand scheme of things.
What we have to do is get the
next generation of workers
ready for the, you know, look,
you've got to have a skill.
Right now today if you have
any useful skill out there
whatsoever, you can find a job in 24 hours
and there's five million
more jobs out there than
there are people to fill them,
so what are we talking about?
There's not a shortage of...
Jobs right now, there's
a shortage of people
who are trained to do the jobs.
If you're a mechanic,
if you're a carpenter,
if you're an engineer,
if you know anything
about computers, you can
find those jobs out there.
The problem is and I'll say
this about this university
but every university, I mean,
we're graduating with kids
with psychology degrees and
political science degrees
and frankly, there's not
a big demand for those.
- Well, just for the record,
there's a great demand
for UC Berkeley graduates,
they do very well.
(audience applauds)
They really, really do.
- That's why you're here.
- And this university
is extremely successful
at educating people to go on
to make very, very good money.
I'd be happy to show you the data.
Sorry.
(audience laughs)
(audience applauds)
- But I think, Henry, that
Steve is absolutely right
that the issue--
- You write that down.
- The issue in the future
is not the number of jobs.
The number of jobs really does
reflect macroeconomic factors
stimulating demand adequately,
it's the quality of the jobs.
It's what the jobs pay and
that's what I worry about.
- Well, the higher paying
jobs, not lower paying jobs.
- Well, we're not seeing that trend.
In fact, for the last 40
years, Steve, you and I
have been talking about this,
median wages have been stuck.
There's been wage stagnation.
- Not the last, no, no,
that's where you and I
part company, for the last 15
years they have been stuck,
but we saw, now, it depends
on what kind of compensation,
but if you look at just
compensation to workers
when you include benefits
and things like that,
in the 80s, we had a big boom
in middle class, you know,
compensation and Laura
Tyson is here, what you guys
did in the 90s, that was a great
period for the middle class
I would argue the 80s and
90s were great periods of
economic mobility for people.
Now it stalled in the last
15 years 'cause I think
we've done a lot of stupid
things that haven't been
good policy, but this
idea that, I mean, look,
I reject this idea which
you say all the time.
Workers are not as well
off today as they were 40
years ago, I mean, does
anybody really believe that?
I mean, come on.
(audience says "yes")
No, 40 years, we didn't
have all these things,
we didn't have the
computers, we didn't have
the technology, we didn't
have the big screen TVs,
we didn't have the medicines
that we have today,
the world is so much,
would anybody really rather
have been alive 40 or
50 years ago than today?
Come on.
- Here's the thing, you
know, 50 years ago, even 40
years ago, we had something
called labor unions,
which gave workers a lot
of bargaining leverage
and right now today, we have fewer than 7%
in the private sector are unionized
and that shows, there's
an absolute correlation
between the median wage, the
decline of the bottom 60%,
particularly men, and the
decline of unionization
and Steve, you and I can
really bore everybody
with a data fight over
whether or not adjusted
for inflation today's wages
for the bottom 60%, 70 or 80%
of males are better than they
were, 40 or 50 years ago.
I don't think they are,
but we can debate that.
I think the point is that
quality jobs are really
critically important
and a lot of the anger
that I saw in 2015 and 2016,
going into the election,
one of the reasons I
think that Bernie Sanders
and Donald Trump did as
well as they both did,
surprising everybody, was
both of them responded
in very different ways to
the anger that so many people
had about a system, a
political economic system,
that was not responding.
- I agree with that.
I think that's true.
People are, but I would
only make the point
that I think it was political,
economic and cultural.
I mean, people, you know,
look, what Hillary said
the other day, you know,
was the way I think
a lot of us conservatives
think that liberals
think about them, you know,
there was a view of these,
'cause I talked to a lot
of these Trump voters,
these middle class voters, and
they were basically feeling
like number one, they
were afraid to speak out
because of political correctness.
One thing that Trump did
I thought masterfully
was just, you know, put aside the rules
of political correctness and violate them
and people would say,
finally, somebody's saying
the kinds of things that we
wanted to say for 15 years
but we get shouted down every
time we want to see them.
These kinds of speech
codes on college campus.
I hope you don't have speech
codes here in Berkeley.
I mean, universities should
be places where you have
open expression, that's
why I so much appreciate
the opportunity to come here and talk,
but too often, conservatives feel like
we're just being
smothered by liberal rules
and that kind of thing, and so
I think it was cultural as well.
- Well, let me just say for the record,
I know you don't mean this, but I think
that Donald Trump has legitimized hate.
(audience applauds)
- I think he's legitimized
a sense of hopelessness
of people and a sense that
their voices aren't being heard.
- Well, the other thing that
you said about Donald Trump
saying that he was going to
take on the swamp in Washington,
he did say that, but the
swamp is deeper and bigger
and broader and fatter and
there are more swamp creatures
than I ever saw in Washington ever before.
(audience applauds)
I want to, I don't want,
this is not fair to Steve.
This is Berkeley and if you
applaud what I'm saying.
This, I mean, I really
appreciate you being here.
I asked you to get a visa
to come into Berkeley.
- No, but look, on this
trade issue, I really want
your kind of reaction, I want to throw out
a kind of hypothesis on this
and I want your reaction.
I asked Laura about this earlier.
Trump is basically gonna
say, we're gonna put a 30%
tariff on Chinese goods
and that's coming I think
in the next week or two, and
that's gonna be a big boom.
I mean, the world is
gonna react in a big way.
That's gonna get Beijing's
attention in a big way and,
you know, I am a free trader
and I want you to react
to this, but look, China,
the report just came out
a few weeks ago, the Chinese
are stealing $500 billion
of our technologies every year.
A lot of that technology
and that knowhow and patents
and the copyrights and
the computer software,
that's made right here, right, in Berkeley
and the Bay Area and Silicon
Valley, they're stealing it.
We also know that they're
building up their military
in China, we also know that
the reason this lunatic
in North Korea has a nuclear
bomb is because China
enabled that to happen and you know what?
I'm with Trump on this,
I think it is time we get
really tough with China and
basically say, you're not
gonna have access to American
markets until you behave
like civilized people,
and you're not doing that.
You're cheating and you
can't have free trade
with a country that's
cheating and stealing.
- Well, I want to say first
of all that China is a rogue
in terms of trade, I
agree with that entirely,
and if you're incorporating
in terms of your definition
of trade, intellectual property
theft, I agree with that
as well.
- What do we do about it?
- That's the question,
what do we do about it,
because I'm afraid that a 30%
tariff or any major tariff
on Chinese goods coming
to this country is going
to shoot us in the foot
more than it hurts China.
- Wow, how could that be?
- Well, it could be
because China is a large
and growing economy and
it is very self sufficient
in many ways.
- But they need access to our markets.
- And also its sphere
of influence is growing.
The United States right
now doesn't play the role
of world leadership that
we played in the past
and I think that when
we are in that position,
China is going to continue
to trade with the rest
of the world, with Europe,
with Canada, with every major
nation, we are going to be left out.
- I don't believe that, I
just don't believe that.
The rebuilding of our
economy that's happening,
in no small part because of
Trump policies on regulation--
- What do you expect
China will be able to do,
because for example, one
of the things you want them
to do is to open up to us,
but that might be even more
frightening than a recession
to them because that might
lead to Americans being
much more in the economy,
maybe a Facebook run by Facebook
in China that really isn't
censored and so on and so forth,
that's really scary to the Chinese.
Do you think that's really
feasible, that something
like that's gonna happen?
- I'm not sure I'm following,
I'm not sure I understand.
- Well, I'm saying that
if we started to have
more opening to China, that
means we have, for example,
perhaps a Facebook we're running in China
that's uncensored because I
think that's the kind of thing
you're asking for, real
free trade, but if you have
an uncensored Facebook in
China, the regime is not
gonna be happy with what's
gonna be on that Facebook.
- Of course, I mean, look,
this is an oppressive regime.
They're tyrants, they are not, they...
Look, the leader there just made himself
the president for life, they're
not gonna have elections.
- So what do you expect him to do,
are there things they can do
that will satisfy Mr. Trump
and us and that allow us
to not impose a 30% tariff?
- So he can basically say a couple things.
Help with disarming North
Korea, right, how many of you
are for that, don't you want
to have North Korea not have
a nuclear bomb, I mean,
we have the leverage
to force them to do it,
maybe we do, maybe we don't,
but we should try, number
two, they have to start,
I mean, this is a point
that Laura Tyson was making
earlier and I think it
makes a lot of sense.
We should...
Get them to buy more of our
stuff, whether it's our weed
or our cotton or whether it's
our copper or our computers
and actually pay us for
it and that's the kind of
trade deal that needs
to be made with China.
- That is precisely the
question, how do we get them?
- Because if they don't, then
they're gonna be severely
penalized, and this is
where I disagree with you.
They can't function as an economy in 2018
if they can't sell to
America's four trillion dollar
consumer economy.
- Well, but there are
two parts to your thesis.
One is that they're gonna
be hurt more than we are
gonna be hurt and secondly
that by doing that,
the outcome is going to
be we get more leverage
and that down the road
they're going to change
their policies.
- They're gonna blink.
- And they're gonna blink.
- You don't think they will.
- I think it's a dangerous,
dangerous game to play
and we could end up easily worse off.
Now a lot of--
- So what's the alternative?
- A lot of our exports,
you know, there may be
an alternative in terms of
using the rest of the world.
The rest of the world has
an interest in an open
trading system.
- Sure, absolutely.
- The rest of the world also
has an interest in rules
that everybody plays by
that are neutral rules
and why can't we, I mean,
we were already making
some progress, I mean, the
WTO, I think was a very good
idea, the World Trade
Organization, and Chinese ascension
to the WTO, I thought
opened the way, if it were
correctly used.
- They don't,
they violate every WTO rule.
- I'm gonna end this because
I think what we need to do
is get a panel of Chinese
experts in here to say
what's the likelihood they
will blink or won't blink.
Because, you folks know
a lot about economics
but I don't think China is
your greatest expertise.
So let's go to another area
where I think you will have
expertise, and that's the 2017 tax bill.
You've already said, Steve,
that you think that it did
good things and simplifying
the tax code in some ways
and also providing tax breaks
that will help the economy.
Bob, do you think that 2017
tax bill was a good tax bill
and that it will really
actually be equitable for people
and second of all that it
will stimulate the economy?
- No.
- Explain. (laughs)
- You know, number one,
I think it's exacerbating
already inequality, number
two, most of the profits,
that extra profits that
corporations have got,
corporations are using to buy
back their shares of stock.
They are not using them to
invest or to increase wages
of average workers, number
three, I think that it's going
to exacerbate our deficit and
our national debt problems.
Now I'm not a huge worrier
about the deficit or the debt
but generally speaking they aren't
going in the right direction
and number four, politically, it sets up
the Republicans and the
Trump administration
for beginning to say, well,
we can't afford you name it.
Medicare, Medicaid, Social
Security, it's kind of
the starve the beast that we saw beginning
under the Reagan administration,
so for those four reasons
I think this was a terrible
idea and to add insult to injury
I hear Larry Kudlow and his new boss
are talking about a second
tax cut, is that right?
- There's some talk about
that, so let me kind of explain
very briefly what we did and why we did it
because I think it's kind
of important for people
to understand the thinking behind the plan
and so Larry and I sat down
with Trump two years ago,
walked him through this, he
got it pretty straightforwardly
and I think, you know, you all will too.
First of all, the heart
of the plan, the gemstone
of the plan was to get our
business tax rates down.
What we've been talking
about for the last 20 minutes
is we're living in a
global economy, the genie
is out of the bottle, it's
not being stuffed back in.
You all aren't gonna just be
competing here in California
against people in Tennessee
and Texas and Florida.
You're gonna be competing
against people in Beijing
and Germany and France
and Spain and Australia.
We've got to get competitive
and we had a tax system,
frankly, Bob, when it came
to the way we were taxing
our businesses, you couldn't
have come up with anything
stupider, you know, we had
the highest statutory rate
in the world, so we were
at 40% when you count state
and local taxes and the rest
of the world, which by the way,
25 years ago was at 40%,
kept cutting and cutting
and cutting and cutting and cutting.
So much so that the rest of the
world was down to about 20%.
We're at 40, ladies and
gentlemen, if you care about
America, you care about
American workers and American
companies, and you want
us to be number one,
that doesn't work, it doesn't
work for us to be at 40,
and them to be at 20, I called
this a headstart program
for every country that
we're competing with.
Why would we want to do that?
So we basically said to Trump,
let's get that corporate rate
down, you know, he wanted
15%, this is an area
where he's a master negotiator.
He stuck with 15% throughout
and that's how we got 21.
If he had said 20, we would
have ended up with 25.
We're right back in the game right now.
All of a sudden, the reason
I think you're so wrong
about the impact of this in
just the first three months
and we're just sucking
capital now back into
the United States in a huge way, I mean,
the biggest economic news
story, ladies and gentlemen
of the last three years,
was the Apple story.
I mean, this is gigantic,
Apple is bringing 300 billion,
not 300 million, $300 billion
back to the United States
and they're gonna invest
it here, they're building
a new plant with 25,000 workers, I mean,
this is a big deal, and those
are gonna be good paying jobs.
Now look, some of that money
will probably be paid off
in dividends or buying up
shares of their own shares,
by the way, why does a
company buy its own shares?
Because it wants to increase
the value of the share, right?
And we have 100 million
shareholders in this country,
they're all gonna benefit from this too.
So that's been a huge
benefit, we've already had
five million American workers,
the vast majority of them
in the middle class, who've
gotten bonuses, pay raises
and increases in benefits,
I mean, the other day
I'm walking down the
street, I was in Dallas,
this Guatemalan woman
comes up to me, she says,
are you the guy on CNN
who talks about economics?
She said thank you for the tax cut.
I just got a $1500 bonus from my employer.
Now to Nancy Pelosi, $1500 may be crumbs,
but you know what if you're
making $40,000 a year,
a $1500 bonus is pretty significant.
So this is going to help in
my opinion, Robert Reich,
middle class workers as
we get more jobs here,
we get more productive,
businesses invest here,
that was the whole philosophy behind it.
It was not and I'll repeat this 100 times.
It was not because we wanted
rich people to make more money
but here's a statistic for
you all to think about.
When you talk about the top
1%, you know, the people
who you say have all the
money, but what do those people
do for a living?
2/3 of them own, operate and
invest in small businesses
and you can't have jobs without employers
and that's what the whole thing was about,
is getting money to the businesses
so they can invest it in America.
- Bob, I'm gonna give you a
second, I just want to say
there's cards on your chairs
and if you want to write out
a question please do so, and
then there will be people
coming by to pick them up, and Bob Reich.
- Well, for example.
You can't have and businesses
are not going to invest
without customers and one of
the biggest problems we have
and businesses face as well
is a shrinking middle class.
I mean, with so much of
the income and wealth
in this country going
to the top, you know,
wealthy people spend a
very small percentage of
their income and certainly their wealth--
- [Steve] They're investing
it in the business.
- But they're not
investing, that's the point.
- They're saving, what
are they doing with it?
- Steve, you're saying
that they're buying back
their shares of stock and
when you say that's great
for everybody, that's not the case.
I mean, the top 1% of
Americans owns 40% of the total
stock market, the top 10% own
80% of the total stock market.
- Well, where do you think
the California teachers
pension fund is invested, all
of this money is invested--
- But that is the reality,
that the top 10% own 80%--
- Well, that's a terrible
thing, we should let people
put their Social Security
money in the stock market
so everybody owns stock.
- But Steve, Steve, the
reality is, the reality is
that taking all of this tax
money, these major tax cuts
and giving it to corporations
in terms of increasing
profits and then turning
around and buying back
their shares and making
the wealthy even wealthier,
that does not do anything
about the underlying problem
of stagnant wages and widening inequality.
Besides that, besides that,
there is kind of an underlying
philosophical difference, and
you and I have been around
this, you know, we've debated
this for 15 or 20 years
about whether trickle down
economics actually works.
And whether there is any
empirical data to support.
- Which there is.
- Trickle down economics.
Which there isn't.
- (laughs) I mean, we
look at the same body.
I mean, the three most
prosperous periods, you know,
for the last 100 years, were
the 20s, when Calvin Coolidge
cut taxes and the 60s, when
John F. Kennedy cut taxes.
Now we actually had a very
prosperous 80s and 90s period
as well when Reagan cut
taxes, you could say,
I know that you all,
'cause you work, you say,
well, Clinton raised taxes but
we did all these other things
We did welfare reform,
we did free trade deals,
we did the capital gains tax cut, I mean,
look, when you lower your
tax rates, you make America
more competitive, you've
got to admit that point.
I mean, countries do
compete, why do you think
all these countries all
over the world have been
cutting their corporate
tax rate for the last...
- Well, that's actually,
you're proving my point
because when we've cut
the corporate tax rate,
what, do you think other countries are not
gonna cut their tax rates?
- They probably will.
- They're gonna do exactly what we do.
That's exactly what this,
there's a race to the bottom.
- But we didn't do it for 25 years,
and the rest of the world
so we had this massive gap,
the other thing we did,
by the way, which I think
was wildly successful was
we recognized that there was
something like three trillion
dollars that was sitting
offshore in Bermuda, in China
and Ireland and all
these countries that have
lower tax rates than us, and
these companies like Boeing
and General Electric and
Apple and Microsoft wanted
to bring the money back but they couldn't
'cause they faced a stiff penalty.
So Trump, I don't know
why Obama didn't do this.
The money was just lying
there, waiting to be picked up.
We basically said, we'll charge
you 10%, you bring it back
to the United States,
we think we're gonna get
about two trillion dollars
back, that's $200 billion
for the United States
government and it's two trillion
dollars that's invested here, I mean,
what's wrong with that?
- In 2004, we did exactly the same thing,
wait a minute, under the same promise,
that it was all going to
lead to big, big investment
and it was going to generate more jobs
and higher wages and it didn't.
We did the same experiment.
- We just had Apple bring
$300 billion dollars back.
I think this tax cut would
have been worth doing just
to get Apple to bring all this money back.
- Let me ask you a question
that comes from something
one of the audience persons asked
and that's this, suppose
you're right that in fact
this is stimulating the
economy and that's great
and jobs are coming back and so forth.
If it is also, however,
going to make the rich richer
and the fact is the tax
bill took the top tax rate,
39.6 and made it 37% and
therefore that's one indication--
- It's much more than
that for the wealthy.
It did much more than
- Well, I'm just taking
one thing that it did
that actually palpably
decreased tax rates on the rich.
Is this the time, given what
Mr. Trump's political coalition
is about, for us to be
going out and making
the rich even richer, is
there a danger to democracy?
Maybe we'll have a great
economy but a lousy democracy
'cause we'll have a lot of
people out there who are really
ready for revolution because
they feel like they've been
so badly harmed and that
this is the new Gilded Age
with lots of rich people
who are treating them badly?
- And by the way, a lot of
those people are right here
in Silicon Valley, I mean,
yeah, we do have Bill Gates
who has $50 billion and we
have the people running Apple
who have billions and we've
got Zuckerberg, who has $50
billion, so what do you want to do?
Would we be a better
country if we just deported
all those people, I mean, I
just don't get this, look.
I think you all obsess--
- No, no, I guess I'm saying,
why did we decrease the tax rate from 39--
- Because we wanted--
- To 37%.
I know there's a technical
reason, but tell me,
was that good politics?
- Yes, I wanted the rate
down to, look, in 1986,
to give you a sense of
how things have changed
in this country, in 1986,
Ronald Reagan had a bill
with Bill Bradley and
Dick Gebphard, Sam Nunn,
many Democrats and we
basically lowered the tax rates
and broadened, you know,
lowered the rates, broadened
the base and that bill that
lowered the highest income tax
rate, none of you are gonna
believe this, but you'll have
to look it up, we got the
lowest tax rate down to 28%
and that bill passed 97
to three in the Senate.
Now we couldn't even get a single--
- Wait a minute.
- We couldn't get one
Democrat in the entire Senate
to vote for a 37% tax rate.
- Bob.
- I thought that that '86
bill was a very good bill.
- Me too.
- And it also leveled
the playing field between
capital gains and ordinary
income and that was one of
the most important aspects of that bill.
But you know, I'm reminded
here, Steve, of something else
that we have debated almost
steadily for the past 30 years
and that is the issue of
economic growth and what really
stimulates economic growth,
I mean, in the 1950s,
the highest marginal income tax was 91%
and the effective rate
was 52% on individuals
and we were growing faster
at an annual rate than we've
ever grown before or since.
You refer to the golden age of the 1920s.
I don't want to live in
the 1920s even if I could.
The 1920s was a period of extraordinary--
- Wealth creation.
- Wealth creation, inequality.
- Yeah, the country got
rich, why do they think
they call it the Roaring 20s?
I mean--
- But it was also
extraordinary inequality and corruption
and it was kind of a period
of time that led ultimately
to the great crash and
the Great Depression.
Do you see any...
Consequence between, in
1928 and 2007, the top 1%
in both those years, 1928 and
2007, had the highest share
of total national income
and we know what happened
in the year after 2007 and 1928.
Do you think there was any--
- I mean, it is true, who are
these people in the top .001%?
They're people, look, you could
take Bill Gates, Zuckerberg,
who's the Amazon CEO, you
know, those five have...
More money than most of
the countries in the world
for goodness's sake so
what do you want to do,
confiscate, take their
wealth away from them?
Look, here's my problem with
the way you see the world
versus the way I see it, I
want everybody to get rich,
right, I don't care, I
want more millionaires
and billionaires in this country.
I want everybody to get rich.
We truly want to create
a rising tide that lifts
all boats, I keep hearing you saying,
there's too many rich people,
no, there's not enough
rich people in this country,
we need more and more and more
people to get rich.
- I'd never say
there's too many rich people.
- But the point is--
- I'm not rich enough and
you're not rich enough.
- What Lapper would say to you is look,
a good economic system tries
to make poor people rich.
It doesn't try to make rich people poor,
and that's where you and I disagree.
You keep focusing on
these people at the top.
All these people in
the middle, number one,
these people are people
who created incredible
technologies, I mean, what
Bill Gates and Steve Jobs
and Amazon have done have
been amazing, I mean,
they hire, I'm friends
with Fred Smith of FedEx.
He's a billionaire, he
puts 100,000 people in jobs
and those are good paying jobs.
- But Steve, I think what you are...
Maybe not hearing what I've
said for the last 30 years
that we've been debating.
(audience laughs)
- It just hasn't come in.
- Is that you need a demand
side, that is you need
a middle class.
- We do,
we are in complete agreement.
- A large, buoyant,
and growing middle class.
- Yes.
- And so I'm not saying
that it's all about
redistributing from the
wealthy to the poor.
I'm saying that what you
need is a set of rules that
actually makes your middle
class larger and steadily larger
and more prosperous and that
includes public investment.
- But I'm not hearing from
people like you, how to do that.
- Well, I was just about to tell you.
That includes public investment
in really good schools
and job training and
infrastructure and public health
and individual health as
well, healthcare is part
of a productive system, you
want to make sure people
are healthy because if
they're not healthy,
they can't be productive,
so for all of those reasons,
public investment is really critical.
You can't have adequate
public investment in all those
areas unless you have sources
of revenue and where is
the big source of revenue,
well, the big source
of revenue is gonna be
either corporations.
Now you just said you don't
want to go after them.
Or it's gonna be very
wealthy people who now have
a huge portion of the total
income and the total wealth.
- So I think you're missing
here, look, we both agree
we want a burgeoning and
upward moving middle class.
You talk about investment in this country.
The word that I disagree
with is public investment.
What our goal is with this tax
cut and we're already seeing
very positive results in
this regard is what we call
cap ex, the capital
investment that's happening
by businesses in this
country, and guess what?
In just four, you know, the
four months since the tax bill
has passed, we have more than
doubled the capital investment
rate than we have under Obama.
One of the reasons the
Obama, you know, recovery
was so flimsy and flat
and anemic was businesses
weren't investing and
now they are investing
and there's a very direct
relationship between
the amount of money
that businesses invest,
when businesses invest more in capital,
whether it's equipment or
machinery or computers,
then workers are more
productive on the job,
when workers are more
productive, right, Bob,
they can be paid more,
that's the reason why
an American worker's paid
more than a Mexican worker.
They're more productive,
so our whole thing,
I mean, if Larry Kudlow were
here right now, what he'd say
to you is cutting the
corporate tax is a middle class
tax cut 'cause those are
the people who will benefit.
The studies show about 60%
of the benefit from cutting
the corporate tax rate,
the benefits go not to the
shareholders but to the
workers who have more capital
to work with.
- Well, you better tell
that to some workers
because they haven't seen any benefit yet.
- Well, it's only been four months.
- But every time Republicans are in,
there is a big corporate tax cut.
There was a big corporate tax cut in 2004
and there was a big corporate
tax cut under Reagan.
- And workers did well in the 80s and 90s.
I mean, why do you think, I mean, boy,
it must not have worked
very well because gee,
we cut the taxes in 1981 and
Reagan just squeaked through
with reelection, winning
49 of 50 states, you know.
I mean, I think the middle
class was doing pretty well
back then.
- Steve, I've got a question for you.
When we sit down with Donald
Trump, and you've referred
to that several times,
you sit down with him
and you brief him, how does he respond
to facts, logic and argument?
(audience laughs)
No, I'm serious, I mean, I
have not had the experience
of sitting down and briefing him.
Now that Larry Kudlow is
there, I expect I will
have many more opportunities.
- Donald Trump is an
extremely intelligent person.
I mean, he really is, he is
an extremely intelligent,
you couldn't pull off what he
did, I mean, he pulled off,
whether you love him or
hate him, what happened
in November of 2016 was
the biggest political upset
in American history, bar
none, no other is even close
to that, and when he started
running for president
in, you know, June of
2015, he was laughed at
and this guy, television
talk show guy, I mean,
he can't possibly win and
so on, and he went out
and built this campaign,
he has a sixth sense about
what the American people
want, and you can call that
demagoguery, but he sure
tapped into something out there
that nobody else saw, I think
he's got the right vision
and his vision is very simple.
It is to put America first
and that's something frankly
Obama didn't do, we had these
crazy climate change deals
and all these, the Iran
deal, all these things.
No, everything Trump is going
to do is gonna make sure
that it's America's national
and economic interests,
not in the interest of
these other countries.
- But isn't that a view of the
world that is a zero sum game
- No, no it isn't.
- In which either we
as Americans win or they win.
- No, no, no, no.
- When in fact, the entire
post war prosperity worldwide
has been a positive sum game,
we look for opportunities
for everybody to win.
- That is a great point,
I want to address that.
No, the Reagan doctrine is very simple.
The United States of America,
and my friend Steve Hayward
is here, he's written
three great biographies
on Ronald Reagan, the Reagan
doctrine was very simple.
When you are strong at
home, you're strong abroad.
When you're weak at
home, you're weak abroad.
Why is it, you know, look at what happened
in the Carter years
when we had Soviet tanks
in Afghanistan and Nicaragua,
we had the hostage crisis,
we were weak at home,
and we were weak abroad.
Trump is gonna rebuild
the American economy,
at least that's what we're trying to do,
so we're the alpha male
in the global economy
and when we get it right
in the United States,
the rest of the world will get it right,
I really believe that.
- But being the alpha
male in the global economy
may be a dangerous thing to do.
That is, the alpha males
of the world may not
actually be the model for
the future of leadership
in the world.
- That's the point, we're gonna
show countries how to do it.
You cut your tax rates, you
have stable money, you know,
you have a light touch with
regulation, these kinds
of things are what, I
mean, look, economic growth
is not complicated and Trump
is focused like a laser beam
on the stock market and
economic growth and I think
that's what he should be focused on.
- But at the same time, it's
conceivable that because
of the tax cut, he's going
to have to cut Medicaid,
Medicare, maybe even Social Security.
Do you think that's a good idea in a time
when we have lots of
people who are worried
about income inequality and
who feel like they're not
moving forward and we're
going to take those kinds
of benefits away from
them, is this the time
to be doing that?
- Trump was very clearly, I
mean, drove liberals crazy.
I was on the campaign,
Trump said, day one,
we're not cutting Social
Security, we're not cutting
Medicare, now it's the
conservatives who don't like--
- [Henry] He said
Medicaid too, by the way.
- He said Medicaid, okay, well.
- I'm not sure he knew the
difference, but the point is,
he did say Medicaid.
- Okay, well, maybe not,
but when it comes to
Social Security and Medicare,
which are extremely popular,
look, I would reform those
programs if I were president
but I'm not the president,
he's made it very clear.
We're not cutting Social
Security and Medicare
and look, the fact is, you
know, everybody in this room
knows we're gonna have to make
reforms on those programs,
right, I mean, we're all
adults, we know if you look
at the demographic situation,
there's 10,000 Baby Boomers
retiring every year, we've
got these massive unfunded
liabilities, we got to
do something about it.
I mean, I'm in favor of
things like gradually raising
the retirement age, I
don't know if you are.
You know, some changes
in the benefit structures
that might lower the benefits
for the highest income
people, that kind of
thing, does Warren Buffet
really need Medicare, I
mean, those are the kinds
of questions we need to
ask, but for the time being,
Trump has said, no, I'm not
gonna cut those programs.
So I don't think it's gonna happen.
But he did say--
- He did say Medicaid.
- But Obamacare and Medicaid
are intertwined now,
they're one and the same
program essentially.
- No, no, they're really quite distinct.
One is run through the
states, one is run directly
through Washington.
- No, what Obamacare
really was was just a
vast expansion of Medicaid
and we're now paying 90% of the--
- That's true too, yeah, but
he also said he would retain
Medicaid, but again, he may not have--
- Okay, so he missed--
- And it's hard to get
those differences.
Bob, how would a universal basic wage be
economically feasible?
- Universal basic income would be feasible
if it's a subsistence wage.
And in fact, some of the
places that have experimented
with it have used a lot
of the public assistance
that is out there and
basically said, this is
going to be a substitute
for a lot of individual
programmatic public assistance.
We're just going to make
sure that everybody has
a subsistence level, you can
design it in a variety of ways,
Henry, and Switzerland just had a,
well, about 38%, I think,
of the Swiss voted in favor
of this, which surprised
people because there was
very little preparation for it.
I don't think there's any way of avoiding
a universal basic income and
by the way, this is something
that Richard Nixon was in
favor of, as you remember.
- Initially, yes.
- As you remember.
- Yes.
- So I think that it's
something that we will see
a lot of agreement on in the future.
- Is a universal basic income a good idea,
or should we strive
instead to try to find ways
to make sure there are
jobs for everybody, perhaps
even a government guaranteed job?
- I think we need to do both.
I think we can do a lot with
government guaranteed jobs,
but as we were just talking
about, it's not so much
the number of jobs that
we need to worry about,
it's the quality of those jobs,
and I am very very concerned
that as automation,
artificial intelligence,
continue to make progress, quote unquote,
we're going to see a lot
of people thrown into
what might be called the
personal service economy
in which they're doing
retail, restaurant, hotel,
hospital, surface transportation,
childcare, elder care,
there'll be a lot of jobs,
but these jobs don't pay much.
And now Steve is right, there
could be some additional jobs
in technician or technical
areas but Steve, you're not
talking about a large
number of people here.
Sufficient to sop up all of
the people who will be...
Facing lower wages, that's really it.
- To Steve, suppose and maybe
you don't want to get into
this kind of conjecture, but
I think it's worth asking it,
suppose it turns out that
there are a lot of jobs
that get lost because
of automation, robotics
and so forth, what are we
going to do in this society?
Are you for a universal basic income,
how 'bout a government guaranteed job,
I mean, shouldn't we be thinking at least
about some of these things?
- So it really is the issue
of our time, it really is.
This is the big one, when so
many of the millions of jobs
that exist today aren't
gonna exist 10, 15 years ago,
and you know, this is the digital age
and it's an incredibly
exciting thing, by the way,
we shouldn't be nervous about this.
I mean, my God, for those
of you in your 20s, I mean,
I'd give anything to be in my 20s today.
You are gonna see the most
amazing transformations.
This is where I think
Bob is so wrong saying
middle class is worse off
today than 40, 50 years ago.
I mean, how can you possibly say that?
Look at all the things that
middle class people have today
versus what people had, you
know, go to a middle class home,
40 or 50 years ago, and
see what they have today.
I mean, the affluence of America
is really an amazing thing
and they will be better
off 20, 30 years from now
than they are today.
- There's one thing that
you've said that I completely
agree with, when you said
that you would like to be
20 years old again, I
would too, I would too.
I would like that as well.
- Let me ask you a question.
- So when it comes to
this issue of universal
basic income, you know,
I'm open minded to it.
I mean, it would depend,
because people are gonna be
so much richer 20, 30 years
ago than they are today
so we will probably be
able to afford to have that
so that everybody has
healthcare, everybody has
a good education, everybody
has a minimal income
that they can get by on, but
here is my worry about it,
Bob, here's, because we will
have enough money for that.
The most important thing that
happiness is tied to work.
There's just no question
about it, and this idea
of just giving people stuff,
I do worry that it has
a negative work incentive
effect and people are not
gonna work and the best thing,
work is where you get dignity
and purpose in your life
and I worry that we're gonna
incentivize people not to
work rather than to have
a fulfilling life.
- But then who's gonna provide
the jobs, is the question?
- Well, that's a good question.
- If it were government, would
you feel distressed by that?
- Nobody knows, I mean, if
I had told you 10 years ago,
just to give you a sense of
how these technological changes
are changing society, if I had
told everybody in this room
10, 12 years ago, the
United States was gonna have
the biggest oil and gas boom
in the history of our country,
there's nobody who would
have believed that,
even people in the energy
industry didn't think
it would happen and arguably
the most important invention
of the last 10, 12 years in
terms of the American economy
has been fracking and horizontal drilling.
It's completely, we went
from a country where people
were worried about whether
we're not gonna have
enough oil and gas, now we've got it,
in five years we'll be
producing more of this stuff
than any other country, my
point is, that technology
came along, nobody predicted
it, nobody predicted
the internet except Al Gore. (laughs)
I mean, all these things, so we don't know
what the future holds, we
don't, we just have to trust
that we'll get this right.
- Steve, you raise an issue
that I want to get your
very explicit read on
and that is, do you think
climate change is a problem?
- I think that if it is a problem,
it's not going to be solved
by these government edicts
like cap and, you know,
this idiotic Paris Accord
where China and India keep
polluting, polluting, polluting.
It's gonna be solved by technology, right?
Technological change and that's
why we have to get richer
because if we get richer, we'll be able
to solve this problem.
- Would a carbon tax be
helpful in terms of stimulating
technological change?
- So that's an interesting
question, so maybe you
and I could sit down
and maybe we could get Laura
Tyson and some of the other
good economists in this
room and we might be able
to come up with a deal
here, I've always thought
there was a deal to be made.
- But George Schulz and other
- No, I don't like his--
- You don't like his plan.
- No, you know, let's
say we have a carbon tax
and we eliminate the corporate
tax or something like that
so we're putting a smaller
tax on capital, right,
and a higher tax on energy.
I could live with that, I
mean, look, there's a deal
to be made here, for those
of you who really believe
that climate change is the
greatest catastrophe ever
to hit the earth, then
let's make a deal, you know,
let's make a deal, but the
deals that are being put out
by liberals, they say, we
want this big carbon tax,
and by the way, we want
to spend all the money on
wind energy and talk
about corporate welfare.
We're gonna give it to all
our friends who make wind
and solar and things like
that, no, the deal has to be,
we give you a carbon tax
and we get lower taxes
on capital so we have more investment
and when you all are ready
to sit down at the table,
I do think there's a deal
to be struck on that.
You wanna shake on that one?
- Yeah, I'm ready to shake
any time and you tell...
The president that I'm ready.
- I mean, I think the
president would be open
to a deal, but not, I mean,
what Schulz wanted to do
is basically combine
two bad ideas into one,
which is just give people
a check, right, everybody
would just have a check,
and you have a carbon tax
and those are two bad ideas.
- But Alaska has a deal
something like that, doesn't it?
- Yeah, they do, they have
what they call the dividend
from all their energy
production and so they pass out,
you know, if anybody wants to
get rich, you move to Alaska
and you get, like, every
year, you get a $5000 check
from the government from the royalties,
but that's a different--
- But that's a similar
principle, isn't it?
- No, well.
I'm not so sure it is because
they're actually getting
a check for producing more things.
You're talking about--
- No, no, no, but here's a
check coming from the government
that is related--
- Well, I'm not necessarily
in favor of the dividend.
I'm just saying it does,
that's the way the people
of Alaska have decided to
do, but they don't have
an income tax in Alaska, so they can't cut
their income tax, they
have so much money from oil
that that's what they've
decided to do with the money.
- Okay, so I'm gonna ask each
of you very briefly to answer
this question, which is,
so you've debated for
many, many years, so can you name--
- [Steve] Do we like each other, no.
- Okay, I'm gonna ask
you two questions, first.
What have you learned from the other
and what do you admire about the other?
Starting with Bob.
- Okay, I have learned from you, Steve,
that it is possible to stick to your guns
in the face of evidence to the contrary.
(audience laughs)
- Ouch, ooh, ow.
- No, no, I think there's
something admirable about that
consistency, I've also
learned from you that
it is possible to be
loyal to somebody who...
Is now president, who
shows absolutely no sign
of intelligence, but,
but, but you, I think
there's some admirable
quality to actually giving him
the benefit of the doubt
up to a limited point.
I think you've gone beyond that limit,
but more seriously, let me
just say more seriously.
I have enjoyed debating
Steve for many years
and even though we don't
see eye to eye on anything,
I like you.
I don't respect you, but I like you.
(audience laughs)
So...
- Steve--
- On Donald Trump,
I mean, I'll just say one
thing about Donald Trump.
You know, I think, I read this
in the Wall Street Journal
today, I think it summarizes everything.
Donald Trump is the worst president ever
except if you look at his results
and the results so far have been amazing.
I mean, what's happening
in this country right now,
the economic revival is
beyond even what I thought
and so the guy is producing results.
The truth is, we don't
have to have this debate
week after week about whether
the tax cuts are gonna work,
right, because the tax cuts are in effect.
We'll just have to see
what happens now, you know?
I'm kind of tired of debating about it.
Let's see what happens, this
is an experiment, right,
and you're gonna buy me the
most expensive dinner here
in Berkeley if we
continue to have 3% growth
for the next three years,
which I think we are,
and I'll buy you--
- I thought the prediction was 4%.
- Well, I think we can
get, 3.5, 4% possibly,
you know, I really do,
if we can continue to do
the right things when it
comes to these tax policies.
Now look, Robert Reich
is an honest liberal.
- 3.5%, I will treat you to dinner.
- Okay, well, but we're
gonna get it this year.
- But if we get under 3%,
you treat me to dinner.
- Okay, you got it, and so look.
I think Robert Reich is an honest liberal
and I don't think there
are enough of them.
I think you genuinely, my
view of liberals in Washington
is what they care about
is power, you know,
that's truly, now you can
say that's cynical, I think
they like power and that's why they want
the government controlling things.
I think you have a genuine
regard for middle class Americans
and I do too and we just see
the world in a different way
but I do admire that about you.
- Let me ask one final
question that I'd like you
to give a comment on because
I think it's a question
that comes from the heart
of people here in Berkeley,
which is that we're concerned
about the future of democracy.
We think that, many of us, that
Donald Trump has done things
that really have reduced our...
Our belief that the rule of
law is what's going to prevail
and so there's a concern about that.
There's a concern that
in his race baiting,
and I really don't know
how else to describe it,
I think that's really
a factual description
of what he's done, that
he's going to lead to
a lot of people feeling hurt
and maybe engage in unrest
and in fact, reasonably be
really upset about what's
going on in this country and
so that he's really caused
a lot of underrepresented
minorities and other certain
groups to feel like he's
really not their president.
Now it is true that maybe white Americans
in the states you talked about
think he is their president
but is division a good idea
right now, is that something
that conservatives, especially
Burkean conservatives,
you're a libertarian
conservative, but a Burkean
conservative, would a
Burkean conservative think
that's a good idea at this time?
Wouldn't a Burkean
conservative worry about
the integrity of government?
- I don't defend a lot of the
things that Donald Trump says
and a lot of times I just roll
my eyes and I can't believe
he says some of the things
he says, but I will say this,
that when liberals call
conservatives racist, homophobes,
Islamophobes, you know, terms like that,
every time that was
said about Donald Trump,
his vote margin went up
because people are tired of it.
I mean, let's have a
debate about gay marriage.
Let's have the debate
about climate change.
Let's have the debate about
our policy with respect
to Muslims, but to just basically
name call people and say,
oh, you must be a racist if
you support, well, I mean,
the other day I was on a
show and I said I support
welfare reform and this
person said I'm a racist.
Really, what is this?
I'm a racist because I
support welfare reform.
I think you all as left of
center people have to think
about whether that's
productive in the debate.
- Well, let me just say,
I think it is unproductive
to use labels, whatever
the labels are, including--
- [Steve] But you already did
tonight, you said you thought
Trump was a racist.
- I said that.
- No, no, Henry can be
blamed, but I can't be blamed.
- (laughs) Okay.
- No, I try, seriously, I
don't think it's helpful
to use labels, whether
it's phrases, but even
left and right and
liberal and conservative
because it means less
and less and as I started
to talk about before, I
think that's Donald Trump.
- Sorry about that, I'm a technophobe.
- Actually, I'll talk to him.
- I'm almost done, all right, sorry.
(audience laughs)
- But I do think it is
important to investigate,
keep our ears absolutely
open to different views.
One thing I tell my students
all the time is that the only
way really to learn is to talk with people
who disagree with you.
- I would totally agree
with that.
- Because that is a way to test your views
and test the facts and test your analyses
and I worry very much, Steve,
and this really I think goes
to the fundamental issue here.
I worry that in this country
we're not really talking
to people who disagree with us, I mean.
Berkeley is a cocoon and
Washington, conservative
Washington is a cocoon.
- Well, so are university
campuses cocoons too often.
- Too often they are, absolutely,
and you know, years ago
I lived in a cocoon called
Cambridge, Massachusetts
and I decided to go 3000 miles to Berkeley
and I didn't realize at the
time that it was the same place.
(audience laughs)
Except the weather is much better here.
But I am open to your ideas for how...
People of different points of view.
- Well, that's why I
debate you for 20 years
because I figure at the end of the day,
you're gonna come around
to my way of thinking.
(audience laughs)
- So I want to thank you both.
I personally feel like I've
learned more about tariffs
and about, I'm serious about tariffs,
that I've learned more about the thinking
that's going on with respect
to the Trump administration
and tariffs, I now have
questions about what China's
reaction is gonna be to a 30% tariff
and I think those are
questions that should be
looked at very, very carefully.
I've learned about what the
rationale is for the tax cut
and some of the issues
that surround that and then
the future of jobs, I
thought we had a really good
discussion about the concerns
that many people have
that jobs might not be as
prevalent in the future
and what do we do about that
and some very interesting ideas about
how to think about that.
I really want to thank
Stephen Moore for coming this
distance and being with
us and I think it was
an incredibly productive conversation.
- Thank you all for being
so kind and generous
with your time, thank you.
(audience applauds)
(gentle music)